now Joel Diaz arrived in the United
States in 2021 on a K-1 Visa before that
he was a computer science teacher in
Cuba earning just 12 dollars a month
he now has a YouTube channel with his
wife Marie who is an American the
channel is about Diaz's appreciation for
America and how blown away he is by even
the smallest of luxuries here here's one
of his recent videos from Fenway Park
[Music]
[Music]
this is really cool
[Music]
that's really
now last month urld has uploaded this
video showing his very first paycheck
from his time in the United States
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
join us now thank you both so much for
being here you know it warms my heart to
watch those videos and seeing the
country Through Your Eyes especially
because you know oftentimes on the news
and in social media we hear people
complaining about a lot of things that
probably seem silly to you but really
taking for granted our god-given rights
enshrined in the Constitution
and so through your eyes can you share
with us what do those rights what do
those freedoms mean to you
first ones
through your speech
that was important for me
and
you know the
the freedom of the dream that's it
something I never have in my old country
yeah we can we can't in Cuba you can't
you know dream
to have better opportunities and of
course Cuba is a Communist dictatorship
and freedom of speech is not allowed
even us doing our content here risks us
being going able to to Cuba to see our
family again
I can only imagine what it means to you
to be freed from the fear that you
formerly felt and to be able to speak
what's in your heart uh here at home
what what are the kinds of reactions
that you're getting from people as you
as you do you openly open your heart to
other people
well we get a range of reactions to be
honest with you we have you know people
who don't like what we're saying about
the Cuban government and communism in
general and then we have lots more
people who really are receptive to to
the content because it resonates not
only with Americans but also children of
immigrants who can see their families in
yoel and immigrants themselves as well
so it's it's a range of reactions to be
honest by the way it's cool it's cool
how about that experience because
well I always put in the in the old
video
and talking to the American people
because when I come in here the first
time
I I saw something spiritual and free
when you see this and you come in within
my age of 38 I'm old and you come in
here I say wow this is freedom that's a
free and you say wow this American
people
appreciate that need appreciate that
because I never have exactly
exactly well I I appreciate you sharing
that reminder because you're exactly
right these freedoms are too often taken
for granted uh but they are freedoms
that we must all celebrate and do all
that we can to protect thank you both so
much for joining us I wish you a thank
you
thank you as well yeah subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight